the next big thing in science is
actually really really small
it's nano hi my name is Aneesa Ramirez
welcome to my lab at Yale University I'd
like to share with you
nanomaterials when you shrink materials
to the very very small scale they have
strange properties let's look at this
effect in action so what color is gold
well that's a silly question gold is
gold of course it's got a yellowish hue
however when we shrink gold to the very
very small scale and make it nano sized
Gold's no longer gold it's actually red
here I have nano gold floating in water
the Nano gold particles are on the order
of a hundred nanometers across although
they don't glitter they're still gold so
what is nano what is a nanometer well a
nanometer is one billionth of a meter
that's billion with a B here I have a
meter stick imagine I were to slice this
a billion times one of those would be a
nanometer if that doesn't work for you
try this on for size imagine pulling out
one of your hairs and whittling it
100,000 times one of those slivers would
be a nanometer it's that small so what
happened to the goal well on our scale
Gold is yellow it's stable and it's a
metal however on the nano scale Gold is
now red it's a catalyst and it's a
semiconductor the properties are
absolutely different and it has to do
with the way that we've changed the
geometry we've increased the amount of
surface another way to say that is that
we've increased the surface to volume
ratio here's one way to demonstrate that
point here I have two sets of eight
blocks one is stacked one is separated
the separated blocks equaled the
nanoparticles as you can see the
separated blocks have much more surface
available than the stacked blocks more
surface means more opportunities for
electrons to interact with the surface
that doesn't work for you let's try this
on for size here I have two pieces of
aluminum foil one is flat one is curled
up they started off from a sheet that
was around the same size but the
latwon still has a very large surface
area this one does not more surface area
just like the nanoparticles is more
opportunities for electrons to interact
with the surface and to create in this
case weird optical properties one of
them call surface plasmon residents this
is the reason why nano gold is red now
gold is not the only material that does
this there are other materials that
behave this way too
cobalt for example here I have pieces of
cobalt it looks silvery and boring
however when we make nano cobalt and we
put it into glass we get a beautiful
blue as you can see in this phase in
fact the next time you see stained glass
that's actually nano in action so
besides these pretty colors
what else can Nano do well in the future
scientists hope to use nano goal as a
way to cure cancer they'll move these
nanoparticles directly to the tumor and
kill the tumor on location that's really
cool
but for now nano materials are used in
solar panels batteries cosmetics
water-resistant pants and antibacterial
socks that's right socks that don't
stink as you can see the opportunities
for Nano are pretty endless what we know
for sure is that the future for Nano is
huge small particles with strange
properties are going to be one of the
many marvels that make the future
products a reality my name is Denise
Ramirez thank you for joining me in my
lab I hope you'll join us for another
material marble